صحيح حضر قبل خمس دقائق الى هذه الجلسه
التي كانت قد حضدت في موعد سابقها العاشره
ونصف صباحا بتوقيت بيروت هناك اجراءات
يبدو امنيه مشدده داخل قصر العدل من قبل
من امن الدوله ويوجد ايضا بعض الاجراءات
الامنيه في الخارج كان هناك يعني وجود
للجيش اللبناني في محيط في محيط كسر العدل
تزامنا مع انعقاد هذه الجلسه هذه هي المره
الاولى التي يحدث فيها رياض سلامه شخصيا
الى قاعه استجواب العام الماضي كان هناك
قاضي قاضي قاضن بلجيكي حضر الى لبنان
وايضا طالب باستجواب سلامه الذي رفض
الحضور بعدها كان هناك القضاء البلجيكي
قال بانه يعني هناك امكانيه لاستجواب
سلامه في بلجيكا بدلا من لبنان ولكن يبدو
ان بعدها اقام القضاء اللبناني باتخاذ
قرار منع سفر بحق رياض سلامه وبذلك لم
يذهب لاستجوابه هناك اذا هذه هي المره
الاولى بعد محاولات متعدده
يعني يعني لعدم الحضور الى هذه
الاستجوابات علما ان رياض سلامه اليوم هو
حاضر في هذه الجلسه كمستمع اليه لاتخاذ
بعض المعلومات منه حول قضايا كما ذكرتم
تبييض اموال واختلاس وغيرها التي تقدم بها
القضاء الاوروبي